Windkraft, das war mal die große Hoffnung für die
Energiewende in Deutschland. Wir waren Vorreiter in
ganz Europa, auf der ganzen Welt und jetzt stecken wir in der Krise.
Es werden aktuell so wenig Windräder gebaut,
wie seit 20 Jahren nicht mehr und warum?
Das wollen wir heute rausfinden.
2019 ist der Ausbau der Windenergie eingebrochen.
2021 könnten sogar mehr Anlagen abgebaut, als neu gebaut werden.
Die Klimaziele können wir so kaum erreichen.
Trotzdem gibt es auf diese einfache Frage zwei Antworten:
Brauchen wir mehr Windkraftanlagen in Deutschland?
Ja, sehr viel mehr!
Wir haben bereits ein viel zu viel an Windkraft in Deutschland.
Deutschland diskutiert wieder über Windkraft
und während wir auf der einen Seite hören,
wir brauchen mehr Windräder – und zwar sehr schnell.
Gibt es auf der anderen Seite sehr
lange Genehmigungsprozesse und ganz viele Klagen.
Wir wollen uns einfach mal angucken,
was sind die Argumente der Gegner von Windkraft
und was haben die Experten dazu zu sagen.
Wir sind hier heute nach Mörsdorf gefahren in den Hunsrück,
weil das hier ist eine Vorreiterregion in der Energiewende
Wir wollen hier heute eigentlich jemanden treffen,
der damit nicht so ganz einverstanden ist und gegen Windkraft protestiert.
Leider ist er hier noch nicht.
Deswegen rufen wir den jetzt einfach mal an.
Weil so ist es schon echt ungemütlich.
Fast überall in Deutschland wo ein neuer Windpark gebaut werden soll,
gibt es Protest von Bürgerinitiativen.
Obwohl laut repräsentativer Umfrage 92 % der Deutschen
für den Ausbau der Wind- und Sonnenenergie sind.
Die Gegner der Windkraft sind gut organisiert.
Es gibt einen Bundesweiten Dachverband namens Vernunftkraft
und darunter viele kleine und größere Initiativen.
Uwe Anhäuser, den wir gleich treffen, ist Vorsitzender
des Bündnisses Energiewende für Mensch und Natur.
Das ist quasi der Landesverband von Rheinland-Pfalz.
Der steht schon eine Viertelstunde da vorne, kommt jetzt aber hier her.
Sie haben eben schon erzählt, dass wir einen kleinen
Ausflug machen können. Wo fahren wir denn hin?
Wir fahren zum Kloster Maria Engelport.
Das Kloster hat die bange Erwartung, dass demnächst
mehrere Windräder quasi vor der Klosterpforte aber hoch
oben auf dem Berg errichtet werden sollen.
Und das macht natürlich das ganze Ambiente und die
Kontemplation, die geistliche Besinnung kaputt.
Wir wollen und das mal anschauen und steigen mit ein.
Auf dem Weg zu Kloster wird klar,
Herrn Anhäuser zweifelt entgegen vieler Experten
stark daran, dass die Windkraft unsere Zukunft ist.
Glauben Sie nicht, dass wir in Zeiten des
Klimawandels eine Energiewende brauchen?
Wir sind in einer Situation, in der wir unbedingt eine
Energiewende brauchen. Wir hätten sie längst schon gebraucht.
Wir sind viel zu spät dran. Nur wir zäumen das Pferd von hinten auf.
Wir machen genau die verkehrten Sachen.
Mit Windrädern, die 3% zum Bruttoenergiebedarf beitragen,
nicht mehr, damit schaffen wir es nicht. Damit halten wir es nicht auf.
Tatsächlich muss man hier zwischen Strom und Energie unterscheiden.
2019 war die Windenergie mit 24 % erstmals
der wichtigste Stromlieferant in Deutschland.
Wenn es um die Primärenergie geht, zu der auch Wärme,
Verkehr usw. gehören, sieht es anders aus.
Da waren es im Jahr 2018 tatsächlich 3%
Es gibt hier inzwischen eine Bürgerinitiative und
die haben sich natürlich sofort an uns gewendet.
Wenn hier irgendwo jemand Probleme mit
Windkraft-Projekten bekommt, wendet er sich an uns.
Im Klostereingang erwarten uns Plakate und Hinweise
auf den Protest gegen den geplanten Windpark.
Und während wir auf den Prior des Klosters warten,
erzählt Herr Anhäuser mir, dass er etwa eine halbe Stelle
in den Kampf gegen die Windkraft investiert.
Die einzelnen Initiativen sind unabhängig voneinander
und wie sie vorgehen, entscheiden sie selbst.
Wenn sie Fragen haben, wenden sie sich an mich.
Und werden dann nach Bedarf munitioniert mit Argumenten,
mit diversen Publikationen, mit Links.
Ich habe einen elektronischen erste Hilfekasten. So nenne ich das.
Wie organisieren sie sich da finanziell?
Jeder nach Bedarf und Vermögen. In der Regel ist
es so, dass wir ganz simple Mitgliedsbeiträge haben.
Bei uns zahlt im Bündnis jede Bürgerinitiative 60€ im Jahr.
Aber wir haben Projektbezogen halt unsere Kriegskassen.
Bei den einzelnen Bürgerinitiativen, bzw. über das Konto des Bündnisses,
das als gemeinnütziger Verein anerkannt ist, läuft da auch eine ganze Menge.
Sie sagen jetzt Kriegskasse. Das ist ja schon ein sehr starkes Wort.
Haben sie das Gefühl, sie führen Krieg?
Ich nenne das so. Naja gut, auf der anderen Seite
haben wir millionenschwere Projektierergesellschaften.
Für die ist das ein Klacks, was wir aufbringen können.
Munition und Kriegskasse. Den Gegnern ist es ernst
und sie scheinen gut vernetzt zu sein.
Deutschlandweit gibt es über 900 Bürgerinitiativen.
Die Zahl der Klagen hat sich erhöht, die Verfahren haben sich verlängert.
Hier vor Ort will eine Bürgerinitiative
den Bau von sechs Windanlagen verhindern.
Geplant wird seit 2017, jetzt ist 2020.
Die Hauptgründe, warum sie den Bau des Windparks ablehnen,
sind vor allem Denkmal- und Naturschutz.
Außerdem befürchten sie, dass sich die Lebensqualität
verschlechtern und Gäste wegbleiben könnten.
Wir sagen, wir wollen unsere Rechte in Anspruch nehmen.
Das gefährdet unsere Existenz, dass hier Leute
auf Erholung kommen können, die ebenfalls sehr wichtig ist.
Wenn sie wo anders geplant wären, wäre das kein Problem.
Also geht es ihnen hautsächlich um das landschaftliche Bild?
Es geht einerseits um das Landschaftliche Bild.
Andererseits um die Emissionen: Lärm, Bewegung,
die hier das Leben stark beeinträchtigen würden.
Können sie uns mal zeigen, wo man
die Windräder sehen würde?
Man würde sie von vor dem Kloster sehen und auch hinter dem Kloster.
Können sie es uns einfach mal zeigen?
Da ist ja schon mal eins.
Das ist Mörsdorf.
Die Straße macht auch Lärm. Wäre eine Windkraftanlage so viel lauter?
Das kommt noch hinzu. Regelmäßiger Lärm von
Windkraftanlagen mit einer gewissen Stärke.
Hinter dem Haus hören sie die Straße nicht mehr.
Aber wäre das so viel lauter?
Hinter dem Haus hören sie die Straße nicht mehr,
aber WA breiten sich überall hin aus.
Aber das da hinten hören wir ja jetzt nicht.
Das ist zu weit weg.
Und das wäre näher als das da hinten...
Bisher, so erzählt er mit, hat die Initiative über
1.200 Unterschriften gesammelt. Sie haben bei Gespräch
mit Gemeinde und Betreiber neue Sichtanalysen eingefordert.
Von den Plänen erfahren haben sie aus der Zeitung.
Ein Punkt, der immer wieder auftaucht:
Je schlechter und je später die Menschen im Umkreis
miteinbezogen werden, desto stärker ist der Protest.
Wenn die SPD jetzt Dinge fordert, wie umliegende Gemeinden
oder Bürger in den Gemeinden finanziell
an den Windrädern zu beteiligen, würde das ihnen helfen?
Das wäre für uns keine Lösung.
Weil es objektive Gründe gibt, weswegen wir gegen dieses Projekt sind.
Es ist nicht eine Frage wie viel bekämen wir.
Sondern es ist eine Frage des Denkmalschutzes,
der die Lebensqualität vor Ort beeinträchtigt werden würde.
Und das versuchen wir, zu verhindern.
Der Kanonikus ist davon überzeugt, dass gegen Recht verstoßen wird.
Wir haben mal beim Betreiber Abo-Wind nachgefragt.
Der sieht das Ganze anders:
Die Gutachter konnten keine Auswirkungen feststellen,
die dem Betrieb des Klosters entgegenstehen.
Wir rechnen mit dem Erhalt der Genehmigung im 2. Quartal 2020.
Auch dieses Beispiel zeigt: Ob Natur- oder Denkmalschutz,
Lärm, versteckte Kosten, wirtschaftliche Unsinnigkeit oder
das Landschaftsbild. In den Augen von Windkraftgegnern
gibt es vieles zu kritisieren.
Und während sie den schleppenden Ausbau feiern,
sehen andere darin eine fatale Entwicklung.
Zurück hier im warmen Studio habe ich mit Prof. Quaschning
von der Hochschule für Technik und Wirtschaft Berlin gesprochen.
Er ist Professor für erneuerbare Energien und für ihn ist Alarmstufe rot.
Mit dem jetzigen Ausbau der Solar- und Windenergie
wissen wir, dass wir weit über 100 Jahre brauchen,
um in Deutschland klimaneutral zu werden.
Und wir haben 20 Jahre Zeit.
So viele Anlagen müssten wir nach seinen Berechnungen
in den nächsten Jahren eigentlich bauen, um die Klimaziele zu erreichen.
Und so viel wird gerade gebaut.
Welchen Kritikpunkt der Windkraftgegner können
Sie am ehesten nachvollziehen?
Gar keinen im Endeffekt. Ich kann natürlich schon sehen,
ich mag so eine WKA nicht. Sie verändert das Landschaftsbild,
ich muss die ja nicht schön finden, ne.
Das ist ja eine Geschmackssache: Windkraftanlage schön oder nicht.
Meistens steht die in irgendeinem Rapsfeld,
das ist ja auch irgendwo eine Monokultur, die mit viel Pestiziden angebaut wird.
Selbst wenn sie im Wald steht, das ist ja immer ein großer Diskussionspunkt.
Also unsere Wälder sind ja in der Regel auch Industriewälder,
die dann Holz liefern am Ende also sie steht ja schon
in einer Kultur- und Industrielandschaft.
Natürlich muss man Naturschutzgebiete und Nationalparks,
da brauchen wir gar nicht drüber reden, ganz klar,
die sollen weiterhin geschützt bleiben: Windparks raus.
Aber wenn man jetzt bei jedem Standort jeden Feldhamster wirklich –
also ich glaube, da ist auch oftmals der Feldhamster
oder der Rotmilan das Mittel zu Zweck.
Man findet irgendwo einen Vogel und kann etwas
verhindern, was man auch so verhindern würde.
Dann werden Menschen zum Tierschützer,
die sich ihr Lebtag noch nie Gedanken über Vögel- und Naturschutz gemacht haben.
Tatsächlich waren Naturschutz und die Vögel
in der Region auch im Hunsrück Thema.
Schwarzstörche, eine Windkatze und Rotmilane seien gesichtet worden.
Später gibt Herr Anhäuser aber auch Folgendes zu:
Das Dumme ist ja, das wir, als Kritiker dieser Energieform
gezwungen werden, uns mit Vogelkunde zu beschäftigen.
Weil, andere Sache ziehen einfach nicht mehr in Deutschland.
Wir haben jetzt wirklich eine Situation, wo die einzige
Möglichkeit, einen irrsinnigen Windkraftbau zu verhindern,
ein Rotmilan oder ein Schwarzstorchvorkommen ist.
Das ist eigentlich lächerlich, weil nach dem Menschen nicht gefragt wird.
Wenn man jetzt Befürworter fragt, dann sagen sie
ja genau das, nur anders formuliert. Die sagen:
Der Rotmilan und die Störche werden vorgeschoben,
d.h. Der Naturschutz wird vorgeschoben, um den Ausbau zu verhindern.
Der Naturschutz ist das einzige Mittel,
was man uns noch gelassen hat
Weil, Menschenschutz gibt es in Deutschland nicht.
So ganz stimmt das nicht. Es gibt diverse Emissionsregeln,
was z.B. Abstände, Lärmschutz oder den Schattenwurf angeht.
Und genau mit diesen Gründen wird oft auch geklagt.
Dennoch scheint es am Ende an vielen Stellen so,
als stünden sich Natur- und Klimaschutz gegenüber.
Für Volker Quaschning sind da die Prioritäten falsch gesetzt:
Eine Windkraftanlage, die ich nicht baue, sorgt ja auch dafür,
dass ich mehr Kohle abbauen muss.
Dass ich ein Stück Wald vor der Windkraftanlage schütze,
aber dafür er Hambacher Forst gefällt werden muss,
weil ich die Braunkohle drunter brauche.
Diese Zusammenhänge kommen gar nicht mit in die Bewertung hinein.
Der positive Effekt der Windenergie auf die Natur
oder auch auf den Klimaschutz, der ist bei den ganzen
Umweltverträglichkeitsstudien gar nicht Gegenstand.
Und das müsste man ändern, dass für die Natur
und den Klimaschutz positive Sachen dann nicht am Ende
durch den Naturschutz blockiert werden, was ja ein bisschen absurd ist.
Doch es ist nicht nur Naturschutz.
Die Liste der Gründe, warum der Ausbau stagniert, ist lang.
Es ist nicht etwas, was jetzt ganz plötzlich kommt.
Es ist eine Katastrophe mit Ansage.
Früher wurden viele Windparks mit Bürgerbeteiligung gebaut.
Es gibt Bürgerwindparks, da sind 1.000 Leute aus der Gemeinde beteiligt.
Dann habe ich natürlich eine ganz andere
Beziehung zu dem Windrad. Jede Umdrehung ist dann
ein Euro und dann fühle ich mich gut, wenn sich
dann das Windrad dreht. Dann kommt jetzt der große Investor,
stellt mir das große Windrad vor die Nase.
Und dann macht jede Umdrehung Krach.
Die Akzeptanz durch kleinere Anlagen hat
man nicht in den Mittelpunkt gestellt.
Man wollte möglichst billige Anlagen durch große Investoren,
große Energiekonzerne, und da hat man die Weichen
hingestellt und das war ein fataler Fehler.
Gemeint ist, dass seit 2017 Windkraftanlagen
ausgeschrieben werden müssen. Das gilt auch für kleine Anlagen.
Es gewinnt, wer am billigsten baut und am wenigsten Förderung braucht.
Und das macht es den kleinen Akteuren schwer.
Außerdem ziehen sich die Gehemigungsverfahren in die Länge.
Wir haben Bundesländer, die immer weniger Flächen
für die Windkraft ausweisen und Diskussionen über Abstandsregeln.
Auch hier macht jedes Bundesland, was es will.
Es ist krass, es ist das erste Mal, dass ich Windräder höre
und genau zum gleichen Zeitpunkt ist da hinten eine Kirche,
die ist schon auch einfach hundert Mal lauter.
Aber, nichtsdestotrotz das klingt so
wie eine Autobahn ein Stück weiter weg.
Windenergie macht ein bisschen Lärm,
wobei das im Vergleich zum Autoverkehr auch relativ gering ist.
Und das möchten halt viele Leute nicht. Deswegen müssen
wir vor allen Dingen an der Akzeptanz arbeiten.
Alle anderen technischen Probleme oder
auch die finanziellen, sind gar kein Problem mehr
bei der Windenergie, aber diese Akzeptanzproblematik
wurde in den letzten Jahren vernachlässigt.
Vielleicht auch bewusst vernachlässigt.
Und das fällt uns jetzt natürlich auf die Füße.
Was meinen sie damit, wenn sie sagen, bewusst vernachlässigt?
Ein schneller Ausbau von Solar- und Windenergie
hat natürlich auch Folgen. Das heißt auf der einen Seite
haben wir dann Veränderungen im Kohlebereich,
die man jetzt mühselig über zwanzig Jahre gestreckt hat.
Die würden einfach zwangsweise früher kommen.
Natürlich müssen wir dann auch andere Bereiche abdecken,
wir müssen uns überlegen, wie wir Speicher machen
und wir müssen Leitungen bauen.
Und das sind alles zum Teil vielleicht auch unangenehme Fragen.
Was nämlich auch stimmt: Aktuell ist unser Stromnetz am Limit,
wenn zu viel super Windstrom generieren.
Wie zum Beispiel bei großen Stürmen.
Das heißt allerdings nicht, dass das nicht ausgebaut werden kann
und Speicherkapazitäten nicht aufgebaut werden können.
Das zeigt zum Beispiel diese Studie vom
Deutschen Institut für Wirtschaftsforschung.
Und auch das Fraunhofer-Institut rechnet vor,
dass die Energieversorgung durch erneuerbare Energien
aus technischer und systemischer Sicht machbar ist.
Herr Anhäuser befürchtet aber trotzdem:
Das Konzept der Energiewende sei nicht zu Ende gedacht.
Wir hätten zu wenig Speicherkapazität und zu wenig Ausbaufläche in Deutschland.
Ich habe mich gewandelt, von dem Menschen,
der vor 6-7 Jahren noch in Kameras gesagt hat:
Windkraft, da wo sie Sinn macht, ja.
Ich sage heute nein, sie macht generell keinen Sinn.
Zu unsicher sei diese Form der Stromgewinnung.
Die Wissenschaft widerspricht.
Herr Quaschning betont, aus seiner Sicht, ist alles da:
Wir haben die Technik, wir haben die Erkenntnis und wir haben das Geld.
Und es fehlt einfach nur daran, dass wir nicht bereit sind, das umzusetzen.
Und das kann ich einfach nicht akzeptieren.
Wenn wir uns weiter blockieren, wird es noch viel, viel teurer.
Würden wir einen Weg finden,
wo wir uns am Ende auch einigen und sagen:
Okay, es gibt auch Veränderungen, die werden dann akzeptiert.
Dann ist es relativ preiswert und wir können es im Prinzip hinbekommen.
Ja und hier sieht man eben auch, was passieren kann,
wenn die Region das Geld aus der Windkraft wieder reinvestiert.
Wir stehen hier auf der Brücke in Geierlay.
Die hat sich zu einem riesigen Tourismusmagnet entwickelt –
aber wahrscheinlich einfach nicht, wenn das Wetter nicht so gut ist.
Im Rhein-Hunsrück-Kreis profitieren die Menschen
aktuell von der Windkraft. Die Gemeinden investieren
das Geld, das sie durch die Anlagen gewinnen in Spielplätze,
Seniorenheime und eben auch in diese Brücke.
Es scheint so zu sein: Wenn wir so weitermachen,
wie wir es gerade tun, kann Deutschland seine Klimaziele kaum erreichen.
Ja, es gibt auch noch Hürden und teilweise berechtigte Sorgen
von Menschen, die gegen Windkraftanlagen sind.
Aber für eine bezahlbare Energiewende aus eigener Kraft
brauchen wir die Windkraft. Und noch haben wir die Chance.